Carrie how do you write a Joe Sherman
song is your third feature that you've
written and directed where are you
coming from as an artist while you're
developing the idea what was going on in
your life haha the I guess the main
thing is I've always wanted to do a
musical because I've loved them as a kid
my parents introduced me to them and
when I got older I discovered West Side
Story and realized oh they're not always
this totally cheeky song and dance type
of films and then I discovered once and
all that jazz later on as well and I
figured you know it's something I wanted
to do and once I found Joe Sherman and
heard his music that was the kind of the
seed that kind of sprouted into okay
this is the next project I want to do
because I've always wanted to and then
meeting kristina rose knowing the
talents that she had where she could
sing dance and act she'd been on
Broadway it really made them kind of
like the team that I wanted reshawna
must surround myself with two to create
something where I felt it hadn't been
done a lot in the independent world yet
you know like it the full-on song and
dance like of going to a Broadway
musical you know and the ones that I've
seen again were more kind of this you
know tongue-in-cheek comedies so this
was something I thought the world had
seen in awhile especially from the
independent level so it was a challenge
that I wanted to put onto myself in the
teen around
and were you hoping for something that
was a little more uplifting especially
in light of what's going on in the
country and what has been probably since
you started making the film the
recession and people in a very
precarious situation you want something
that's funny because you know it has
been called a crowd-pleaser by a lot of
people and I never set out to
specifically try to make it where people
would really feel uplifted in general it
was more about the journey that I had
gone through it myself as an artist the
you know dealing with artistic integrity
because you've mentioned I've written
directed three films I've been you know
director for hire for two others where
it was more dealing with producers and
other scripts were you know it wasn't
really my voice but I still had to do it
and that was something I felt I want to
explore through Joel Sherman film about
having to do other people's work and is
it really yourself or not and that was
the main kind of thing I was exploring
as well as its relationships around you
and I guess the byproduct was most
people think because of the music and
outcome of the film is where they find
it pleasing to them they you know
something they feel that has touched
them in a way
you